real gangsters are on Wall Street the
real gangsters are in the government and
I was like damn these mother get all
this money and they not Rising their
life something got to change for me
something got to change and so I just
started listening to them every day and
I started comparing it to the streets a
good business is just like a good
Hustler a good business has great
product they have great clientele a
great Hustler has a great product he has
consistent clientele a good business on
the stock market has what's called a mo
a Competitive Edge that keeps his
competitors awake poverty is lack of
information lack of resources money is
infinite they've never stopped printing
money the problem is getting the belief
to understand that getting the Bel that
you're capable